welcome to this video I'm soaking I'm
soaking Iceland right now getting better
what I come on let's let's do something
else I had a request to play Knight f6
and I played it in one or two games but
only there was one or two games how to
play that him he didn't play an early c4
yeah still probably he will do that now
on the next move no okay yeah still a
very healthy position from White's point
of view just developing what about
Bishop g4 night not quite sure how to
develop here should I play knight c6
really
you
and this Bishop 1c8 is not particularly
great maybe yeah maybe I should try to
exchange it on g6 make a square on c7
for this night okay intending bishop g6
I was hoping that he plays on page three
at some point but II if he didn't do it
who came just develop yeah he's not
doing anything fancy I'm just developing
pieces not doing much but not doing much
wrong okay taking on g6 now feels like
it's helping me a bit with the
controlling f5 and age five okay I tried
to do a little bit of something try to
keep the knight on d5 if possible now
maybe he can go for for this b 3b 3c
form
it takes on b5 I wonder if I can
actually take with a/c pawn probably not
the best move theoretically speaking but
at least I'm complicating matters a bit
I just did I take with the a porn and
just be three probably yeah if I take
with the C porn does he really have
anything on the iphone I don't think so
now i have queen c7 controlling see form
yeah maybe what i'm doing is just yeah a
bit too ambitious maybe
but at the moment it doesn't look like
he does that he manages to place you for
sure I'd like to do yeah should this
bishop can potentially be a liability 97
okay night this Knight to g5 Queen 83
mate this is a possible plan yeah that
term it's dangerous maybe go here so
that h3 is controlled and also I'm they
can play c4 I'm such an idiot I just
allowed him to place you form yeah great
I just I'm just loving this it's like
playing a completely passive moves all
the way and then I allow him the only
active plan okay
yeah yeah on the other hand maybe Bishop
f8 was just too passive the bishop on
his heaven was watching a boom or the g5
s square bit instead of this I should
probably have played queen d 7 I know
then is he can can play C for anyway
yeah I don't know now wyd now assess
it's just just better Bishop f5 as a
possible move not quite sure what to do
with the night maybe Brooke be a door
something and this I didn't expect but
it's not it's not too without its points
kunai deform but let's let's see if I
can get the sea for porn
I'm taking it three times and I don't
see how I defends it rookie form but
this is a very strange move still a
strange move okay f5
yeah maybe this is all good for white
look hom possible very much possible at
least if is yeah of course I overlooked
that
hmm I wonder I wonder I wonder at the
end of all this it takes takes takes if
I can go for a pin on the FL
what would think you can
takes takes takes on b6 looks you on
Bishop c1 rook a one probably this is
not working for some reason okay but the
only thing I can I could think of at the
moment check route see one it has it's
it's it's really working amazing the
only question is how do I stop the beep
on okay I can play rook c8 be eight but
it's the some better way to do it and
I'm probably not you should be eight
I'm just in time 1c7
it's quite amazing that I'm still in the
game
time warning
he's playing all that was 16 seconds all
right great check check check check
check sheriff what can you do lagging
for Fitz on time very nicely played by
him I thought I can I can hold this but
you played this very precisely
yeah absolutely no no chance at all here
I could baby map it said it's just it
just just gone yeah amazing yeah of
course I deserve to lose I simply forgot
about about c5 but maybe the position is
suspend any way or this some f five
assists according to the computer just a
losing move here it says i have no moves
at all yeah the problem is probably if i
move the Queen somewhere he's got
bishops III yeah i mean the the whole
problem was that i allowed see fall
before that it's just just normal
disposition rot yet I don't know maybe
about equal but after allowance afore I
got very good play alright thanks for
watching